The greatest lecture or sermon you will give
is your example. What you do will matter far
more than what you say. As my grandfather
often said, "We were duty-bound to do the
right thing, to do unto others as we would
have them do unto us." In a sense, they were
teaching us that what we wanted to do did
not define what was right, rather, what was
right defined what we were required to do
and what we were permitted to do. At the risk
of understating what is necessary to preserve
liberty and our form of government, I think
more and more that it depends on good citizens
discharging their daily duties and their daily
obligations. Some of you will most assuredly
be called upon to do the very hard things
to preserve liberty, perhaps even given the
last full measure, but all of you will be
called upon to provide that firm foundation
of citizenship by carrying out your obligations
in much the way that those around you did
and so many did during my youth. You are to
be the example to others that they were to
you. The very existence of Hillsdale connotes
independence. It understands that liberty
is an antecedent of government, not a benefit
from government. Do not hide your faith and
your beliefs under a bushel basket especially
in this world that seems to have gone mad
with political correctness. I admit to being
unapologetically Catholic, unapologetically
patriotic, and unapologetically a constitutionalist.
After the constitutional convention in Philadelphia,
Benjamin Franklin remarked when asked what
they had done that they had given us a republic
if we can keep it. Are we content to let others
do the work, to let a few give the last full
measure for liberty while we consume the benefits?
If so, perhaps one day, we will run out of
other people's sacrifice and courage, and
perhaps we will run out of courageous people
willing to make the sacrifice, but this is
Hillsdale College, and you are special, that
shining city on a hill. Hillsdale is a trustee
of the heritage that finds its clearest expression
in the American experiment of self-government
under law. You are men and women of Hillsdale
College, a school that has stood fast on its
principles and its traditions at great sacrifice
and great cost. You are men and women of Hillsdale,
steeped in the best traditions and principles
of our great nation.
If you don't lead by example, who will? I
have every faith that you will be the beacon
of light for others to follow, that city on
a hill that cannot be hidden. May God bless
each of you now and throughout your lives
and may God bless America. Thank you.